22 Emmy nominations I mean what does
that mean to you and how good is that
everyone loves the show so much and
everybody that works on it cares so much
and it's passionate and I've never
worked with a better group of people
then then that goes for the cast crew
everybody involved is just top-notch so
it I think it's well-deserved yeah we
were like a boy or like a kind of a
royal Gollum all of us within our
precious the show we loved it so much
and then to have everybody else love it
it's amazing good way to start the
second season that's a good way to start
any season me too and at the top of the
heat fair enough yeah yeah okay so with
that said why do we have to wait so long
for the next season you're shooting
right now right yeah shoot first share
later yeah just started last week so
I've got a little work to do first share
but why why are you why are you sharing
chole right you knew this was coming
yeah yeah are you writing slowly or
what's going on no and there's no I mean
we have this movie that form like the
kind of genesis of the world that we're
playing but there's no books there's no
mythology so we're kind of creating it
from ol top and then you know once
that's done and we have the next season
written now but production quality that
we try to go for it's basically like
making a giant movie there will be all
sorts of travel and explosions and
adventure and you know so it's a it's a
giant endeavor and take a little time
you also have strong women in this is
there is that from your pen or is that
just an overall I'll push of the show
well I mean I think part of what through
- this was the chance to see the West
and even sci-fi from a kind of new
perspective and then when you're writing
for women like the women that we wait
for the strike just it's just so natural
because you see it in our actors and
they bring you more of it to life
they're incredible yeah basically great
robots that's why I keep robot Oh
comic-con what's the experience like
coming here to comic-con and have you
had a chance to really soak up the fans
it's pretty wild
yeah I mean I was filming until like
4:30 this morning so I'm not exactly
sure where I am about to afterwards
which is gonna be really exciting do you
walk the floor in costume right yeah you
put on the costume but I got to yeah
like got a Wonder Woman yeah other what
costume do you wear will you go on the
floor come Wonder Woman I think the
choice I saw you before you look great
is they hated the beard in the Wonder
Woman there you go when I actually saw
guys I saw him to be seen I saw him -
yeah that's all the legs first from
behind tomorrow it's a lot of hair but
that's cool that's cool to another level
Wow rocket now I know you can't tell me
any secrets but can you give me a
general direction of the season - where
are we going what's gonna happen
it seemed like something was gonna come
out of your mouth music please
no no I was just like I can I can give
you my reaction to it I ain't never
hearda give me your reaction because
maybe your reaction will tell me
of course that's must oh my god people
are gonna freak out like that was
basically reaction is off course and the
rest was gay do you have those reactions
when you read when you open it up and
you're like oh yeah
what it never fails to blow my mind
every time and I'm on it and I expect
greatness and I expect my mind to be
blown and it takes it even further it's
almost like it's poetry it's weird it's
so beautifully written SuperValu you
read this and in some of the best
writing that I've ever read in my
lifetime as an actress I that's why it's
so special to be on the show because you
hope for roles like this and to be a
part of something so I guess some kind
of mind blowing and it changes it kind
of changes how you think about life
everything it's effective changed me as
an actor and I feel like hopefully it
such as people the same way
we also got the like the serialized
experience that the viewers got when
during the first season of getting the
scripts every couple of weeks like like
a Dickensian novel in the newspaper kind
of style you know we got those twists
and turns you know on a real time every
other week in the same way that you
would when you were watching the show so
it's kind of thrilling to we get that
sort of soaked version of it as well as
any meeting people who might have missed
they're catching up and binging like
crazy and then going being like Oh have
you seen Wes were like you're a year
late bro but what was it like shooting
in Utah how does that if you got to
experience Utah how was it
I find that that was the most immersive
experience of the whole crazy might get
emotional just I truly truly it was it
was it was like it was like a band of
friends and the family got together to
fight a war together that they believed
it was just it felt like we had a
mission and we had it was so artful but
we just knew it had to be as good as the
rest of everything and I don't know I've
never seen three units filming together
at the same time partly and your
locations I never knew places like that
existed in the world that's not green
screen that you've seen this new
expansion of all shanthi products
everyone asked me what was it like
working with all that green screen we
weren't we were really going to perspec
really in these locations really doing
these things
[Laughter]
it's inside that's the deal there
it's amazing you had so much fun yeah
but really honestly will it ever speed
will the process that the gap in time
speed up because we know there's going
to be a third season - will there be
will there be a time where you shoot two
seasons at once or what you we have to
survive I would having the first season
I would have never stopped shooting if I
didn't feel like by the end of the first
season I had to rest because it is so
what we're doing is so complicated so
intense so much work so much goes into
it so much preparation and shooting it
is like running a marathon every day but
the most exciting it's like running a
marathon well like you're getting chased
by polls will everybody there any night
and how are you ready I think I'll be
filming that night he'll probably make
your work won't be yeah no you go to
work none of us like each other
so those things are never fun mm-hmm how
many of you watch the original but I
waited till after we were done know what
shocked you about it once you saw it
nothing was a thing surprise you uh no
not really I mean I'm a huge Yul Brynner
nerd so he's just fantastic and the
performance really held up so I think I
was I thought I thought it was gonna be
more dated actually and you know of
course in some ways it's an old film but
uh but his performance really cuz really
how's that yeah yeah and did you
purposely say we're gonna leave a lot of
that behind we're gonna leave a lot of
the
all original Westworld behind well you
know I actually haven't seen it until I
wrote the pilot really enjoy you want
the pilot out Washington yeah well
because and I knew what it's about
and I felt that what one of it one of us
had seen it and if I just kept kind of
fresh on it you know the first thing
that I heard about is Crichton was such
a genius and the idea kind of mashing
together these two awesome genres like a
Western and sci-fi that already spoke to
me so much and then you always want to
kind of put your own spin on it and
bring new life to it and so for me it
just started with well what if in a
vacuum we start dreaming up characters
the people that we would want to
populate this amazing world with and
then we found these guys and we were off
to the races
you know HBO shows come they get they
blow up and they give big Game of
Thrones huge now it's gonna end and you
guys are really in position to be that
crazy you know most-watched or most
beloved show in the world and are you
ready for to kind of digest that and
have you thought about it I hope so
I mean the theme is of the show it's
it's yes it's exciting and entertaining
and fun to watch and to figure out but I
think like you were saying the the
writing and the themes and why we're
making the show and what it's about it's
it's eerily relevant and beautiful and
so I hope it reaches as large of an
audience as possible because I think it
really forces people to ask questions
about themselves and about their own
reality and it's it's so immersive that
you kind of start feeling like a host
the alternative being the least watched
show that's not a good thanks
like not a good desirable but look how
hot were those costumes when you're with
the costume can you tell what it seems
like yeah I got you told cuz we film for
so long you oh yeah you had another
you're all weather are you just sweating
in there it melted yeah but it adds to
the look bro and we of course it so it's
like you know it's a very sad shirt
inside it's a very specific kind of man
who could pull off leather trousers and
yes we have one